bruno daroux beaucoup de réticence
ukrainienne ces dernières semaines à
propos de cet accord oui il y avait
beaucoup de craintes de la part des
ukrainiens évidemment qu'ils ne font
absolument pas confiance aux russes donc
il ya eu des négociations compliquées et
notamment les ukrainiens refusé de
déminer la bande terrestre autour
d'odessa et les eaux territoriales qui
peuvent permettre de mener à rodez c'est
tout simplement parce que il disait que
si retirer les mines et les russes
allaient en profiter pour lancer une
opération amphibie ce point n'a été
réglé les mines sont restés et c'est la
marine ukrainienne depuis les ports
comme au dessin qui va escorter les
céréales
jusqu'à la limite des eaux territoriales
ukrainienne est en fuite ces navires
vont se diriger vers les détroits du
bosphore pour
rejoindre un centre de coordination
conjoint ou là on va contrôler que que
tout est bien parce que l'inquiétude des
russes c'est qu'il ya des armes sur le
chemin du retour qu'ils soient embarqués
en faveur de l'ukraine pour aller aider
l'armée ukrainienne voyez que tout ça
s'est déroulé dans une ambiance
extrêmement déficiente de part et
d'autre sous l'égide de l'onu c'est un
beau succès pour secrétaire général de
l'onu et surtout c'est un grand succès
pour le président turc on le rappelle un
donc ce centre de coordination conjoint
à istanbul c'est évidemment important la
turquie renforce son rôle de médiateur
qu'est ce que gagne la russie dans cet
accord bruno globaux de la turquie
justement on a vu le président r doan
lui sort quand même assez grandi puisque
vu sa situation géographique il a su
jouer là dessus pour jouer un rôle
essentiel puisque les détroits turcs
contrôler l'accès à la mer noire il a
parlé de sa fierté d'avoir contribué à
résoudre cette crise voilà et 2,3 depuis
lille à hillary la raison derrière
puisqu'il a amené même si les on a vu
que les signatures se sont déroulés
séparément russes et ukrainiens en fait
il a permis quand même qu'il y ait la
signature de cet accord et du coup tout
à l'heure on a vu qu'il a parlé d' un
premier pas mais il a dit après le plus
important c'est que la guerre se termine
donc on a compris qu'il va relancer son
rôle de médiateur dans ce conflit très
bien bruit lors les russes donc puisque
interrogé sur les russes et les russes
et évidemment c'est assez
habile d'abord il en avait besoin
puisqu'ils ont aussi besoin d'exporter
leurs céréales et leurs grains donc il y
avait un peu une question de nécessité
mais au-delà de l'aspect purement
économique y est très important pour les
millions de personnes qui attendent ces
céréales et ses engrais ça permet à la
russie aussi de revenir un peu sur la
scène diplomatique internationale
puisque la l'accord a été signé en
présence du secrétaire général de l'onu
ça veut dire que la russie n'est pas si
isolé que ça n'est pas la réhabiliter
planeta paria ça lui permet de continuer
à exister sur la scène internationale et
évidemment ce n'est pas négligeable pour
moscow et à avoir quelques recettes bien
sûr avec ses grands oui bien évidemment
cette expertise seront notamment
distribués en afrique on en a notamment
parlé tout à l'heure et au moyen-orient
également merci beaucoup bruno va
retrouver